you
whoa okay well this tournament just
jumped right up on me I could have sworn
there were
before
it started by okay here we go we have a
super blitz arena three-minute time
control in a quick transposition to
Sicilian land let's play Knight c3 first
maybe I go d4 and maybe I say now let's
go let's say no
playing fishy fishy
where was fishy Vichy when the three
checked erm I was just going on this is
he's an excellent three cheque player
anyhow
okay
[Music]
could I just castle I'll just take and
then castle let's get on the e-file
really quick let's play d4 I want my
bishop to be unmasked so let's see what
they do they're gonna help me to unmask
my knight capturing on d4 castles is
probably best and I may insist on okay
well forget about that let's uh let's
jump in right now if they cancelled I
think I would have tried something like
Bishop to e3 what do I do here how about
we put pressure on this night I may be
looking to just take and then take care
some direct stuff hmm okay let's go here
it's a half-open file I don't know that
I want to take with the rook if they
play Knight takes Knight this is
definitely an option let's go here
Bishop h6 I could maybe consider a
sacrifice I thought about just a3 before
Queen to d2
okay lamb oh so they're really they're
really trying to hurt me but aren't they
just giving me up on here
let's try this first as fearing this
kind of stuff I don't know
state something quick be practical
throwing a question to the bishop okay
so I don't think I fear this pin so much
because I do have a file to work with
and can I not just actually take here
and then here
so I'm up upon and the pond that I'm up
is the be pond I don't know how how
healthy a pond it is but yeah I'm up a
pond
let's keep the bishop I think here could
take with the bishop they have a bit of
a time edge but I am up a pond let's go
here I guess just anticipating a bishop
move I don't want there to be a strike
at b2 this still might be an idea you
know giving up a pond I think that's
what they're prepping
um
tell you what I'm gonna do this it's
very ugly but I just want to rule out
any 94 idea and I just want some time
basically to consolidate so let's go
here back the bishop up and I don't know
go from there them okay well but we come
over here
evening out on the clock let's just back
up that move I was not expecting them
okay if I took with the pawn they have
this okay now this is excellent I don't
mind a queen exchange here takes c3
and first thing I want to do is make
sure this bishop does not get activated
and now my king is gonna take a hike
over here where's that and I headed I
don't know I'm not sure can't get there
so easily
or can you let's get this bishop doing
something flush the rook away careful no
mr. Mac lows too trapped maybe let's get
my king here I'm doing this so that I
can activate my rook he doesn't want to
stay tether to the defense of the b2
pawn I want to keep control over f5 so
let's take with this one just kind of
keeping things
cool oh they have to block otherwise I
get the bishop okay we'll go for this
exchange and now let's uh break things
open a little bit night check I do not
want to take opposite color Bishop's
let's try this let's go here and here I
wanna get this guy keep that night boxed
out yeah
get that pone I think I'm gonna get that
pawn
now we just get to trade everything and
win this win this in game and it's a
pretty simple to convert and in fact I'm
going to promote this pawn not give him
up and there's plenty of time to to win
this one just know Stanley it's okay
they resigned back to tournament land
and well yeah there we go there's
exactly a hundred in here I am in thirty
second place and yeah that one took a
bit yeah they gave me the a pond and
they were they've been helpful to me
with the capture on c3 and then the
Queen exchange so that's really what I
was looking forward to in that position
because I think the primary reason I was
a fan of the Queen exchanges because I
had the more weakened kingside structure
playing f3 I know that was in no way a
forced move
but yeah okay
I was I wanted the Queen's off so okay
how about we put the nightie here so
they're not going for d4 huh
all right let's let's lash out some with
d5 okay I'll take with the night let's
try this if I take with the pawn there
could be some pressure on d5
yeah I'm cool with keeping this
structure
and that's a very interesting move okay
let's just go here playing very fast
okay we're gonna try clean here and I
think I just want to go one step one
little baby step and then Bishop here
going to they're playing so fast
why aren't you thinking a little bit at
least I don't know you
I go to then there's this type of stuff
and I don't think I'm ready to deal with
that stuff you know I'd have to play
maybe be five or I don't know just felt
a little bit too loose holy cow man you
need to start thinking
he's just gonna throw just whatever
seems most devastating just do whatever
feels is aggressive that's the plan by
my opponent first move that looks
aggressive do it
okay well this is again dangerous
dangerous okay we're gonna try this
night here they're definitely gonna go
night there and we're gonna defend like
this and weaken some squares yes I love
free pieces back to tournament
okay and just like that were Nathe
they made them one of the more
aggressive moves there Knight to f6 but
it that aggressive move gives me a free
piece those players are tough to go
against I know like these are these
quick one move threats for the shorter
time controls you know you do have to
pause to figure out what in the world is
going on okay we got an h-file to work
with and they're wasting some time to
make sure my bishop my rook doesn't see
h7 directly so also they gave up their
better bishop and how's this guy ever
gonna play let's put him here who's
gonna argue with those Knights who have
fish up here what's going on why my
opponents giving me stuff free stuff
let's take with the night I guess right
here I could take him out I don't have
to that I could play off 3d for clean
exchange I'm cool it I'm off upon and he
is going nowhere Bishop g4
maybe just this I don't want that bishop
killing this pivot square from my king
rook so let's welcome some trades and do
I have anything forceful like this let's
do this right now how is this night ever
gonna play he goes here in this pawn
kind of laughs at him right here this is
the threat and my king is going to find
it much and actually no K the bishop
isn't trapped let's just die improve the
King okay and now we're gonna go here
the bishop has to run home he didn't run
home he's a goner
probably resigning here dr. Zorro that
was probably Mouse lipno now they're
giving me stuff they resigned back to
tournament land thirteen twelve nine
eight eight is where I stand
119 in this one forty five minutes to go
okay let's see who we get next
[Music]
Queen masters in a game no he's not
Queen masters here
alright let's throw the Sicilian out
there the c3 Sicilian hmm alright let's
go with d5
and are they gonna play D Phi D form
I haven't played d4 yet okay so I think
because they weren't so direct in the
center I'll have time to deploy my
bishop outside of the pawn chain and
then e6 backing up okay and I think I
want to take right now no I don't think
I have to I could still do this there is
no push here I thought there wasn't to
push there let's go here because that's
why I put my what are they doing am I
not just winning up on here I'm winning
upon no there's no discover check that's
why I will put my bishop on this square
okay so they're just there gamba ting
upon okay
noted let's castle night see trees
hitting with tempo I think I just need
to run home
but it's it's a bit uncomfortable
I want a queen exchange I think let's
offer one
Queen b3 Queen to b4 I'm on the bishop
it's easy to miss they might play Queen
c2 they did its a knee-jerk reaction you
know you're down upon your opponent
offers you a queen exchange let's avoid
it and see it so many times that these
lateral moves by the Queen are
overlooked for whatever the reason I
think our mind is programmed more to see
the Queen moving along files and
diagonals than ranks anyhow what can we
do to punish teamwipe that Knight was
controlling d4 not anymore so let's hop
in and you were just up a piece and a
pawn on top of it
and soon maybe much more let's see
where's the Queen go offering exchange
okay let's just take that rook is
demoted and we could just continue
taking stuff yeah let's go with this and
then be a trading machine that's the
plan where's it safe square for my
bishop I just want some security let's
get a flight square cancel out one of
the moves here I might try for this
don't know if I should have allowed that
okay let's start pushing some phones
over here I do have a majority step my
king up there doing the same
and probably drop my Bishop back just to
let my my pieces see the world will do
this the Knights gonna look for that
square but I also have this square to
work with if the night ends up on c4 I
just go here and offset them and here
stops any pressure against my Bishop
it's a really really tough guy back up
the bishop to still watch over the 95
move got these squares covered what's
the route gonna do
I could look to flush the night away
okay look going to challenge the night
they have that and now we improve the
King
forward and my bishop might take up that
c3 post if allowed he's not allowed so
we're gonna have a role reversal first
and my bishop defend this guy and now go
into pac-man mode defend
hide and push and they should be
resigning soon I think um what to do
take another pond they resign back to
tournament ok 17 12 12 9 142 in this one
40 minutes to go this the top guy he's
in a game ok how's his game looking
quick assessment he's looking like he's
up upon took on h7 with check ok there
we go so this is the number 2 guy I'm
done with the Sicilian for this game at
least let's try a French defense line up
there we go French defense and ok well
we'll go in for this line here
will allow them to grab some space if
they want if they don't want it though
so we just have offsetting pawns d4 vs
d5 structure and I want to deploy my
bishop here that's why I went with this
first to cancel out any Knight b5 ideas
and I'm cool with a queen exchange um I
have an interesting choice here what
he's to capture with I'm gonna I'm gonna
go with the bishop i I did think about
this and then castling by hand let's try
this
here I think I'll do this okay yeah
let's do this and I want it I want to
challenge this Knight really soon I'm
not sure which way is best in playing
like like a machine this is something a
computer would do very direct play very
direct play
all right let's castle f5 I run away and
how about we go here first yeah this is
this is this is difficult
alright I'm going to do this I'm in a
I'm in a pickle here that night is super
hmm that night is super you see if I if
I did this night move when the bishop
was on e6 I end up getting trapped or
something with f5 okay so let's get the
night out the way they gave me one
square to work with can I make use of h3
are they gonna rule that out they rule
that out so what next let's see if I can
maybe provoke this move I don't know
what it really accomplishes if they
don't play that then I go here and if
they do that one we're later then I move
my bishop back they're not allowing me
to do that
and now they're pushing with g-form hmm
okay I'm gonna try this and then maybe
flush that night away
oh my god okay oh let's try this
let's jump in here they should probably
just back up or not okay I
do this it's not fun to do that
every move is very very direct very very
direct
so Knight takes pawn I got to do this
surgeon man surgeon
maybe one day I get here
this is very very strong play by
teamwipe I feel like I need to try and
win on time and let's try here it's Rome
in a pin now they have takes here and
they're gonna take here and then they
have that stuff this has all been
calculated no they're going with that
huh
holy cow
tough day at the office for team black
for sure um I just don't know what to do
I just don't know what to do I have to
somehow try to win on time
I don't see how I managed that night
here oh boy that moved first
precision man precision there goes my
bishop why are they waiting to take my
rook oh because they want to give mate
they had something better oh wow okay
they played much better than their
rating that's for sure
all righty we big speed bump they're 12
that was one of the more direct plays
I've seen in a while
very nice
all right let's get back on the horse
here g5 yeah and this is not the first
time I've seen g5 yeah g5 now I have the
H file I've seen this in bullet play
okay I don't have to take cuz they're in
a pin okay Bishop d3 castles bring the
Queen out and what do we do here well
let's continue developing this app Hahn
does a very good job of killing
basically the Queen side they're still
in a pin I'm just gonna go here I want
to control this square so let's get all
the pawns rolling huh I've given that
square but now this is a connected
passer he is really deep let's squeeze
this one I have a lot of space could win
him - let's do it
like giving me stuff okay we're on the
seventh ranked rook takes rook we take
with the pawn and we're we're promoting
next
um let's let's see if we could force
them to take my rip on h7 not quite so
we're gonna get some pigs on the on the
seventh rank I didn't have to react to
that I could have played here first
okay are they gonna move okay
there we go Bishop has to go to the
corner okay now I'm gonna do this I
really want them to take okay they
finally did so I'm getting a queen next
this is one of the most dangerous pawns
you could see one step away from
cleaning and attacking a knight some
that happened recently that's how
Carlson's
loss and the feed a World Cup could have
could have ended he resigned before it
got to that point but that'll got a
little uh idea his present okay thirty
two minutes remaining okay this guy
again we're gonna have to try to win on
time because I don't think I'm capable
of beating this guy okay we're gonna
have to try to win on time that's that's
the game plan going into this one I have
zero confidence that to my skill is good
enough to beat this guy so we're gonna
have to try a time a time technique can
can I burn the time before this guy is
able to beat me up
we're gonna see all righty so they're
taking about three four seconds every
move five six seven let's see all right
so far so good so far so good let's just
take here maybe we get something against
h7 maybe
let's just jump in here I get some
trades maybe maybe Queen f3 Queen f4
okay let's run exchange Knights and it
challenged me and I think I have to just
Castle here if I went here there's chop
chop and then rook to e8 stuff mm-hm
207 how could I enter a position where
they're gonna have to exhaust a lot of
time before they could be me
yepper alright let's try this
maybe they struggle a little bit
the B for advance yeah I knew you were
gonna do that so I might just uh you
know flounder use a floundering
technique
and that's the plan maybe maybe we
flounder just a little bit 150
um yeah now they're they're being fancy
with the Bishop 142 they're still going
for this of course they are of course
they are I can't take their my bishop my
bishop is uh he was obstructing my
Queen's defense of this if I took like
this then there's that and then my
knight is just dead
now it's running to take here but you
know they have it all up they have it
all figured out
figured out all right well now I'm just
absolutely busted
hang-up
clean exchange and then maybe get here
they have a simple idea to to go in for
that I think 118 the upper
okay I'm gonna be giving up my night
still gonna try to win on time still
gonna try
why are you taking forever to take my
night man just take him he's free come
on buddy
he's free
Oh an again in G five one-minute warning
move hurry up
I will take care
I think I need to get rid of one of the
rooks
54:53 it's a race against the clock
folks
to race against the clock
49
um can I prolong this game any longer
oh it's so tough
try this
the night's gonna go in there of course
there you go
I know it's coming I just can't do
anything about it not here
night oh man okay you're on f2 I didn't
even see that you only have 36 seconds
thirty-six seconds that should be plenty
though
maybe they play
it's too slow that
or touchdown
maybe they do this
20 seconds
they're really slow
13 seconds are they going to move
I'm going to give a check nine seconds
come on man
we go for perpetual
oh you're down on time man I'm so sorry
you had me though man oh man you had me
so good oh man I'm so sorry you lost
there AHA I'm so sorry man I I want to
quit I feel so bad beating you my god
I am so I'm so sorry I I really want to
just quit this dream that was awful what
I just did there oh man I am so sorry
you just weren't fast enough you just
weren't fast enough man
ah that happens alright that happens you
just weren't fast enough man you needed
a little more juice
you didn't have enough juice left man
just a little bit more man a little bit
more juice
ah man okay
so close so close
he's gonna get me next time though he's
gonna get me next time redemption I have
no idea what's going on in this game by
the way
whoo there was a little bit of lag just
then okay I like my knight he's Superman
he's a Superman night do we want to go
we were gonna go queenside and look for
these ideas whoa I want to stay right
here no I don't want to leave the site I
want to stay right here we're looking at
these things fishing poles stuff
okay we're gonna go here and then there
and then see what happens
who
let's just go here we don't want any
night trickery
not just okay that night is such a
dangerous man
so what do we do
we flush him away I don't I don't know
going with a pond yeah those kind of
moves scared me going Queen here and
here that's a nice one for Corona
ah
okay we're going to take even though it
gives them the G file
and now I want a queen exchange because
my king is weaker and I'm just gonna do
this right now
I don't even want to play something like
that okay well the Queen's are gonna be
off I don't know how dangerous this pawn
would be let's see I think I could I
could work around this button this this
pawn here yeah if they push here here
I'm basically treating this as if the
Queen's are already off the board
because the exchange cannot be avoided
yeah
so Queen takes Queen
and what do we do we take this pawn
and I can always support it with this
no Knight takes pawn there's that takes
rook takes and then Bishop takes Knight
no thank you
so I gotta go a bit more I have to treat
this a bit more delicate I got to get my
rook out of the line of fire do this
next and then maybe think about rook
here it's coming at a snail's pace I
realized what yeah and there's also that
moment but here is just already
threatening rook takes pawn so if they
have to do this that's no fun
and we're even on the clock
rook to a a rook to d8
and then we're threatening this pawn
here so how are they
are they coping with the the pressure I
have against both of their pawns
our Kings way out of the action if he
goes here I have this I'd rather get
that pun
and then take out their bishop and then
their pawn everything collapses from
there so that move huh
it's very interesting trial
can I cut all this pawn if I do this I
think let's see
one minute Oh a little bit of an
advantage
so
I think we're just going to snip this
pawn
let's give that a go
and if this then I I scooped him up in
this way I have to be so careful though
because this rook could get really
active
maybe the approach should be
- just take this pawn you idiot
why would I need to do that why man
hmm
okay we got this one they're in control
now a little bit of a time edge
and now I just want this I want one rook
trade then it becomes technical I don't
have to worry about any fancy tactics
- Brooks tactical one rook technical and
now we I want to put him into a passive
state
I don't care I'm just eliminating this
pond as soon as possible
gotta go kick it into a higher gear and
now we're gonna know we're going to take
care
rook trade
cut the king of
improve the King
go pawn hunting
got one fun
looking for fur we're looking for one
more
here we go just protect everything
time
they got no time no time back to terment
where do we stand
I'm in third who we gonna get next the
slowpoke
now he's banned I had no idea
Wow the guy that I played in lost to is
no longer here hmm
oh man just another clown with an engine
man watch out watch out it's just
another clown with an engine
oh man I'm so sorry you got caught
red-handed buddy shame on you
disrespecting this great game man mmm
oh man it was a good game though right
it was such a good game you lost on time
though your hand engine core
coordination was just not up to up to
the task man you got to improve that
engine hand-eye coordination you know
what I'm getting at you're too slow
you're too slow okay what's going on in
this game
um let's grab some space space invaders
B 4 a 4 B 5 sneak in a flight square and
everybody's happy
No
let's do this first
I want to combat this idea of e5 if here
I'm not going to allow the knight to
take my bishop so easily we're gonna
jump in here not take with the pawn
because that drops c5 so we're going to
take care if they flush my bishop away
and their knight is uh experiencing some
difficulties actually he's a difficult
piece to get rid of because of this h6
move if ever f6 then I have Knight to g6
or who knows what actually be mate pawn
push allows I'm actually I was actually
threatening a mating to just then let's
secure e5
and from here let's push in the center
I think they're ready to play off six
but yeah if ever this
I can't take with the night just yet
because this Queen sweeps in with
authority hitting everything all the
dark squares so I want to keep this the
dark square Bishop I do now I don't have
a dark square Bishop to offset him so I
need to have my pawns do do that okay so
from here we get to a file that's
important and we're striking at f7
they're striking at my knight do I care
about that maybe I do
maybe I don't let's go let's go with
this okay and he's super passive right
now but he may later emerge somewhere
over here so
is now the time for a flight scar I
think I like going for a flight square
right now and say you know what you take
me and oh there's that move
that's a nice move okay
I think we're gonna have to go with a
queen exchange no we don't have to do
that let's try this I really want my
queen over here it's not happening now
let's try this
a passed pawn something maybe maybe they
free up this guy to break down their
structure somewhere maybe my seat pon
becomes past so an important decision
and now we're gonna pivot here
if I went here I think I'm inviting
another rook move like that and now we
go here defend my night and finally
throw a punch
and their missing Queen takes this I
guess they don't care about that they
know they do see that they just don't
care about it why don't they care about
that
they'd be caring about that
Knight to f4 is simple enough now
I also do this
let's just spend a second or two
let's see
or route 2 f2
[Music]
Queen takes pawn first and then ripped
f2
let's let's run with this
yeah let's let's run with this first
I thought about this because I am
defending jeetu
but I'm allowing some checks I don't
know I wouldn't be allowing any checks
I'd be threatening a check
how about just something simple double
up
I don't need this rook defending d4
anymore so double up on the F file and
then we're ready for Knight to f4 Knight
to g6 yeah this this is the way forward
and their Bishop is really just a tall
pawn
and okay we're going to take take here
he has a job that's the other thing to
know and I could get away with this move
rook takes our queen takes rook Knight
to g6 and I get the Queen
allowing this variation and they
resigned okay 4126 24 222 and i'll
less than 15 minutes are only gonna get
a couple more games in there I don't
think this top guy is gonna get caught
have we played at all no we haven't
played any games
okay 41 26 24 so top three guys
oh well this guy is right on my heels as
well see in a game already it's the
number 19 guy how about we try
I don't know g6 that's different
um yeah g6 D 6a 6b 5
yeah let's let's give this a go
okay there they're rolling out b5 but
this is a bit of
what am I trying to say let's go with
this and b4 is a bit weakened after a
four so let's see mmm taking
with ipon let's let's take with the
night actually so
now let's just develop I maybe could
have gone in here straight away
let's Castle Knight f3
what do i do on night 2 F 3 forget about
it
now let's let's just keep him sitting on
a nice square I thought about this but
this is an open position so I should be
keeping
the options open for these guys okay so
how can I really hit my opponent
night to be 490
five is springing to mind D 5 D 5 here I
don't know how I feel about that
it's maybe an idea
here here and then push let's go for
that let's let's let's break in the
center now that last move is masking the
queen's view of d4 so i think this is a
a nice moment to sneak in this move I
could give up the night
to this you know if they give up this
guy and no that would have been bad
maybe
now this this is this should be very
good now
it's important to note that after a
sequence of exchanges on this square
there's no Bishop move with check other
my otherwise my queen would be a goner
Oh God or we don't want that so let's
take with the bishop I guess they're
probably just going to castle now yeah
very sensible and now probably here just
open his eyes off throw a punch
maybe Knight to g3 Bishop takes well to
exchange Queens okay their bishops
pinned now
let's try h5i try to clamp down on this
structure
way behind way behind on the clock
wanna get another developing move in
there
four would be very crazy town
very crazy town
okay dark
Bishop I need to hang on to him let's
just back up
and that movie yeah
that's extraordinary
let's do this it's very ugly I'm also
way down on time
on time they could okay let's go here
Bishop's in a pin
flush that night away
I'm untangling now some
and I think I want to put my bishop on
the longest dog and I'll know
how are things looking if I do that yeah
there's no longer any pressure here for
the moment
even a move like this should be a bit
irritating no the night cannot move
me
okay now the knight can move let's go
here looking for that Knight g3 move
let's keep pressure on that pond and
look for for this
defend that guy they're moving really
fast
let's defend the night
they might go further the win of upon No
Queen takes rook takes
my night is enormous
here I think is okay I'm way down on
time I got to pick it up
faster
okay
and I get to the second-ranked maybe
let's take care
my night is really good on f5
I always have a check that I could
insert if my rook is uh is attacked
rook exchange I'm just gonna win this
pawn actually
and the conversion should be pretty
simple I'm leaving evening out on the
clock
and I'm just gonna shoo him away I could
have captured and won that one there but
I'm valuing my night a real lot
they're breaking down my structure well
this one pond restricts these too but
he's he's a bit of a dead pawn
yeah I don't I do not like how I'm
attempting to convert this this is very
poor and I'm going to be losing that
pawn
losing the other pone as well that could
have gone after that guy
this was very poor conversion it's
losing now
tricky night as all I got my night may
be trapped somehow
I need to hang on to him
and get upon
should just push him
okay
even if I just have a night and nopon oh
there's the deadly fork
they're down that time oh man that was a
really poor conversion that was a nice
shot that they did there with a five
breaking up my queen side structure when
they played Bishop d4 I guess I should
have just snipped that bishop I didn't
anticipate the a5 move I think that's
what it was a five broke up my structure
and then they ended up with a pass C
pond completely overlooked that okay so
seven minutes in change we're just going
to get one more game in there top guy
will not get caught and maybe I could
try to berserk one game huh
ooh they resigned I don't get berserk
points for that but I got +4 so yeah
that's helpful
to go berserk in this next game and if I
get it I guess I'm going to end up
getting second because he doesn't have
any fire
maybe we end up getting paired up no
he's in a game so he got the killer
Knight likely the the last game here
okay
something simple
and c4
fancy here
drop back
keep that night stranded I'm fine if
they give up for Bishop for night and
strengthen my Center 95 is no issue
they're getting a little fancy there
maybe too fancy
let's see
I think they might be getting just a
little too fancy Queen takes bishop
Knight takes Queen
Knight takes Queen
looking pretty good for me with this
sequence they have night c2 but I also
have night F night to c7
or that move that I totally missed that
they could just take there
okay let's just know if I can I was
considering King to d2
yeah flushing
soon this is just a very temporary night
post and let's just get a flight square
at this moment and avoid any
possibilities of my Bishop being trapped
he has a nice cozy home on h2
and let's let's do that now Bishop takes
there's this in-betweener and then I
drop my bishop so
fish of H through Bishop h2
and
do this I just want to offset the night
kick them away next and then redeploy
this guy
I don't I could look for this kind of
stuff that would drop upon but I feel in
this position I could play within the
structure I don't need to do anything
with my pawns
I'll give him a shove but beyond that
I'm ready to just now activate pieces
I think immediately
okay so you want to go with that
really looking for this kind of caveman
stuff maybe
[Music]
okay let's go here threatening this and
fell for it
okay
yeah they wanted to set up this
structure to negate my bishop
they missed the little little pawn stab
me for
hopefully in a clean way
the bishops kind of silly and I have
this squared and I'll work with that's a
whole so we're gonna plant him there
soon
or even the rook all right probably just
get all my pieces playing I'm also
throwing a punch at this pawn after that
last move f5 wasn't protected so we
could have some mass exchanges if we end
up in
a major piece lists ending this pawn on
h4 will soon drop
in the center they have less than a
minute three minutes left on the clock I
could pick up it pick him up at any
point
and let's just stop any idea of them
expanding first Perry my opponents
threats and Mayan persist I will not be
going away they won't be going away
so here threatening a million-one
Bishop to e2
and
[Music]
yeah let's flush them back
Oh
and even see that the head I move
let's get him out of there they're ready
distract my king
for this
but three versus two on the kingside
yeah they're completely boxed up their
King can't put pressure on a three as
long as I keep my Bishop here
you know this this structure cannot be
disrupted and
yeah not much more to say
just start advancing now
and do this
I could take in advance this guy
sniff him next
I guess here
and I'm ready to push now
no time
how stalemates
now stalemates
they're down on time and the pair
with that are closed and so in the end I
finished with a 36 is this guy in a game
oh he's in a game
I'm going to get
let's make sure I'm going to get second
yeah come on you could hold out for one
minute right
it looks like black is ready to win
he fifty seconds left let's see how this
one finishes
so you gonna move Magnus
Magnus gonna move
they're just not a good defense okay
some lateral defense there
only 30 seconds left that's not gonna
this is not gonna finish oh there is
this kind of a threat though they could
always do a clock ticking tactic yeah
okay I'm just gonna jump away we don't
want to miss the confetti 53:36 34:29
258 players and all
okay and that should do it
let's have a look at the pages
officially second okay page two three
see all the participants
I see tsunami of pawns in there
Undertaker le
Nik is in there
Bojan to
and plenty of others
a lot of pages a good crew
all righty from beginner to master I
just spotted and that's going to do it
to the 257 of you
good games Oh alrighty
you